وصل الملحق الدفاعي السعودي اللواء
في Waze Alpha Waze إلى بينساكولا
وقد التقى ببعض المتدربين العسكريين السعوديين
الذين يخضعون
لتدريباتهم في القاعدة وهم بالضبط
ما يفعله هناك ، وليس من الواضح أننا
نعرف عددًا منهم  عدد
السعوديين الذين تم احتجازهم هناك في القاعدة
التي تم استجوابهم حول
الحوادث المحيطة بإطلاق النار ،
وقد أعرب بعضهم عن رغبتهم في الخروج
من القاعدة ، ونحن نعلم أن المحامين قد
شاركوا أثناء عملية الاستجواب هذه
ولكن على وجه التحديد طبيعة هذا الاستجواب.  الزيارة
وما يحاول الملحق الدفاعي
تحقيقه غير واضح ، لكن
العاهل السعودي ولي العهد
قال التزامًا مطلقًا
بدعم الولايات المتحدة.  التحقيق نعلم أن العديد من
هؤلاء السعوديين قد تم استجوابهم
بأنهم في بينساكولا كانوا
متعاونين في هذه الأثناء كنا
نتعلم المزيد عن مطلق النار نفسه
محمد الشام روني على حساب تويتر
يعتقد المحققون أنه
يلقي ضوءًا جديدًا على العلامات الحمراء المحتملة
التي  تم إغفاله على الرغم من أنه في الدقائق التي
سبقت الهجوم ، قام بتغريد
شيء كان معاديًا لأمريكا في الأشهر
السابقة كان أيضًا يغرد أو
يعيد تغريد الأشخاص الذين
عبروا عن آراء معادية للسعودية في الماضي ،
أحدهم مؤلف أعاد تغريده
أن المؤلفين كانوا  في السجن السعودي ،
شاهد المؤلف كان في السجن السعودي منذ عام 2016
الآن حقيقة أنه كان يعيد تغريده
ربما كان يجب أن يرفع الأعلام الحمراء
ربما هذه الأسئلة التي يتم
طرحها الآن بالتأكيد هو شيء
لا بد أن يبحث عنه المحققون في
NIC Robertson CNN الرياض  المملكة العربية السعودية